Every year, Forbes magazine
releases
a list of America's
biggest givers.
And in 2023, these 25 individuals
or pairs made the list.
It includes people like Google
co-founder Sergey Brin...
and Mark Zuckerberg and
his wife, Priscilla Chan.
These are the piles of money
Forbes reported each of them
has given away.
Collectively, a whopping
$196 billion
of lifetime giving.
That's bigger than the GDP
of most countries.
This giant pile of money
has done a lot of good...
but it's hiding a more complicated
and problematic story
of billionaire philanthropy
in America.
We'll show you how.
The Forbes list ranks
the biggest givers
by how much they've given
over a lifetime.
Biggest to smallest.
And they only measure dollars
given to charitable recipients.
That means it excludes money
parked in a foundation.
We'll get back to that.
And money pledged,
but not paid out.
You’ll see here that Warren Buffett and
Bill and Melinda French Gates
are standouts.
This chart we're making
measures the givers
current net worth.
Adding their philanthropic giving to that
we came up with the percentage
of their net worth
they've given away.
So Forbes puts Buffett's current
net worth at $106 billion...
and he's given away
$51.5 billion in his life...
which puts him at 33%.
Bill and Melinda French Gates
who are divorced but still do
philanthropic work together...
have a collective net worth of $109 billion...
and have given $38.4 billion away.
Most of this group's donations
go to poverty
and public health around the world
and education in the US.
And together, Buffett
and the Gates's
created the Giving Pledge.
A promise by the world's wealthiest
individuals and families
to dedicate a majority of their wealth
to charitable causes.
That's over 50%.
They're almost there,
but not quite.
These 13 givers
have signed it, too
including Facebook co-founder
Dustin Moskovitz and his wife,
Carrie Tuna....
Jeff Bezos’s ex-wife, Mackenzie Scott
and Michael Bloomberg.
The other signatories fall around here.
Only two of them have made it
over the 50% line.
The banker — T. Denny Sanford —
has given 53% of his net worth away.
And Duty Free Shoppers founder
Chuck Feeney...
almost every last penny of his fortune.
George Soros hasn't signed
the Giving Pledge
but he belongs here, too.
He's given 73%
of his wealth away.
The eBay founder and his wife
go here
and everyone else on the Forbes
list falls roughly in this area.
Over the course of their lives
they've given 12% or less
of their net worth away.
In the least flattering zone
of the chart
the highest net worth
but the lowest proportion
of it given away...
is Jeff Bezos.
The founder of Amazon is
the richest person on this chart.
His $117 billion net worth dwarfs
his $2.7 billion of
philanthropic giving.
It's only 2.3% of his wealth
over his lifetime.
For context
that's about as much as what
Americans, on average
consistent only give as a proportion
of their disposable income
per year: About 2%.
Bezos’s money has gone
to various causes
like fighting climate change,
education...
he even gave $100 million
directly to Dolly Parton.
Bezos’s philanthropic reputation
at this point
is kind of that he doesn't have one.
It's kind of hazy is what
a lot of experts have told me.
That's Whizy Kim
senior reporter for Vox,
who covers billionaires.
A lot of people speculate that
that's one of the reasons
he’s made this recent announcement
of “I’m eventually going to
give my net worth away.”
There was a lot of pushback,
a lot of speculation around
“Hey Jeff, why aren't you
more involved in philanthropy?”
This chart helps us see who
the real standout givers are...
those who give most
of their wealth away
and those who hold onto
their enormous fortunes.
Even if a certain individual
is very generous.
If overall, this class of people
just keeps amassing more
and more money
we've got to look at ourselves and ask
“Okay, what are we doing wrong here
and how do we reverse this?”
All this money creates what
the Institute for Policy Studies
has called top heavy philanthropy:
Where individual wealthy donors
make up a large portion
of charitable giving.
Since 2011, mega gifts
of $1 million or more
from single donors have
been growing.
If you are a relatively small institution...
that receives funding from
a very large philanthropist...
they take their money away,
you are in trouble.
This chart breaks down
charitable tax deductions
by household income level
since the early 90s.
Nonprofits used to rely on
the broad support of the population.
In 1993, 77% of charitable deductions
were taken by households
making less than $200,000.
Today, that chart has almost flipped:
Households making more
than $1 million
were taking the most
charitable deductions.
So just a handful of people
are deciding
what merits philanthropic money
and how these causes should be solved.
Ultra wealthy donors
tend to give to different causes
then the rest of us.
An analysis of the Chronicle of Philanthropy’s
top 50 donors
shows that they give to education
more than the causes
non-wealthy donors give to:
Like to health...
a lot to religion, the environment,
and international affairs.
That could mean a billionaire
giving $500 million
to his alma mater for a new
building on campus...
or another giving $750 million
in one single donation to charter schools
in 20 US cities.
A relatively small amount of money
can have a great impact
on a specific school district or
a single charter school.
The top 50 donors
are also more likely
to give through a private foundation.
Most of the people on the Forbes list
have had their own private foundations
or they give to them.
Here's how they work.
Donors make large charitable gifts
to a foundation
in the form of cash,
assets, or stocks.
In return, they get huge
tax benefits immediately.
But the foundation only has to
give money
to actual charities at a rate
of 5% a year.
That means money
can stockpile in here
donors reap the tax benefits...
while charities may only get
a trickle over time.
The Forbes list only counts
this money
that foundations have
already given to charity.
Not the money parked here.
Meanwhile, this money continues
to enrich donors.
There's another way
billionaires donate
that the Forbes list
doesn't count at all.
Donor advised funds
which are more secretive
by design.
These are charitable
savings accounts
that allow the donor
to be anonymous
and offer even bigger
upfront tax benefits.
More importantly
they have no reporting or
payout requirements...
so it's difficult to tell
whether the money is going
somewhere good
or just lowering the donors
tax bill.
Donor advice funds have been
rising in popularity...
meaning collectively they are housing
billions of dollars yet to be
paid out to charities.
As of 2020, that figure
was $160 billion.
And the huge multibillion dollar
endowments of foundations
means they have a lot of power.
Like the Gates Foundation.
In terms of global
public health...
the Gates Foundation does
got a lot of credit...
for their work in improving
vaccine access
for preventable diseases for
very young children.
Since they've been doing their work
in child mortality rates
like infant mortality under 5
has gone down a lot.
Their foundation is also
the largest private donor
to the World Health Organization.
Which tells you a lot about just
how much agenda setting power
they have.
And what kinds of public health
problems to prioritize.
The biggest criticism is that
it's undemocratic.
Former Enron executive John Arnold
and his wife, Laura
have been advocating for reform
of donor advised funds.
By lobbying Congress
to require them
to distribute funds
within 15 years...
or for donors to only get
a tax deduction
upon distribution to charities.
Others advocate to increase
the payout requirements at foundations
from 5% annually to 10%.
These types of reforms are
small fixes to the system.
But if our country didn't have such
dramatic wealth inequality...
we wouldn't have to rely on
the charitable whims
of these billionaires
to begin with.